[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs la maîtresse de
cérémonie de la 39e soirée des Césars
Cécile de
[Applaudissements]
France
bonsoir
merci je suis heureuse et très h d'avoir
été choisie pour vous présenter cette
39e cérémonie des
César personne ne sait mais c'est pas la
première fois que je présente la
cérémonie puisque je l'ai déjà présenté
de 1985 à
1989 dans ma chambre chez moi à amur
mais c'était un peu pareil que
maintenant en fait je suis donc très
contente de vous
retrouver
thank you so much
mrantino myorious
Bastard scet
johon in
real oh
guum
auré
[Musique]
philiip oh as
Frari Jérémy
iron oh my gosh oh my
gosh
ad AD
not oh
my mais quelle année mais quelle année
de dingue oh là là une année de dingue
pour toi pour toi pas pour
toi quelle belle année pour le cinéma
français et même si comme d'habitude
c'était la
crise ce fut une année pleine de
surprises ce que cette année nous montre
de
mieux c'est que la chance sourit aux
audacieux le public fou les vieilles
formules le bun la il faut du sexe et un
maniaque et quand on fait un film de
famille on ne sait pas si le fille c'est
une F le public voir du neu Parj numéro
9 fa arrête d'être frilleux une histoire
d'amour c'est trop peu toi j'ai des
filles toi j'ai des vieux mais des deux
les cheveux
[Musique]
bleus des
franceasy on reçoit le même scénario
c'est moi quiurait d' faire lein au
vé
les film c'est comme la
météo c'est pas facile
d'anticiper tu
[Musique]
veux pour éviter les
FIAS on avit les
copinagères
allez nous sommes tous là ce soir c'est
pour C la
cérémonie
[Musique]
comm c'est V les talents sont tous là
ils ont loué leurs habits de Gal le
monde entier nous les envie comme dit
Madame pH si onach pas l'épiderme ils
vont pas rester
[Musique]
SPID en
nu it tout osé et
défriché des territoires il
[Musique]
explorer
alors il est où Antoine de cône hein et
ben ça y est on peut
commencer merci les gars vous êtes trop
beau